el mundo es un lugar hermoso algunas
veces caminamos afuera y simplemente nos
deleitamos pero otras veces como somos
programadores nos gusta programar todo
caminamos afuera y nos inspiramos y
luego corremos a casa para programar una
simulación del mundo que nos rodea una
hoja que cae a la tierra dando vueltas o
tal vez un fuego ardiendo en un bosque
seco
podemos programar simulaciones de todas
esas cosas y podemos hacerlo aquí en can
academy usando javascript processing
leyes y un poco de matemáticas en este
curso de simulaciones de la naturaleza
pensamos en cómo y por qué las cosas
funcionan de la manera en que lo hacen
en el mundo real y luego investigamos
cómo podemos trasladarlo a un código
haremos muchas simplificaciones porque
el mundo real es muy complejo y no
siempre necesitamos modelar esa
complejidad con el propósito de lograr
una simulación interesante y por
supuesto nuestras computadoras no pueden
reproducirlos así que cada vez que un
programador simula la naturaleza siempre
logramos una copia por debajo del 100%
del original pero creo que estaremos
realmente impresionados con lo que
podemos hacer especialmente en el
navegador empezaremos por hablar de la
aleatoriedad una técnica que
probablemente ya has usado en tus
programas y después el ruido una forma
más sofisticada de esta podemos usarlas
para modelar el movimiento de objetos en
el mundo como alguien perdido en el
bosque pero muchos objetos no se mueven
aleatoriamente así que después
introduciremos vectores y fuerzas lo que
probablemente ya has visto en tu clase
de física y puedes encontrarme
programación como aplicar fuerzas a
nuestros objetos para que ellos puedan
acelerar sobre la base de ser empujados
jalados y repelidos por todas las cosas
que están a su alrededor para hacer que
nuestros objetos puedan girar en su
propio eje mientras se están moviendo
repasaremos trigonometría y llegaremos a
las fórmulas para la aceleración angular
también podemos usar trigonometría para
modelar cosas como péndulos y ondas que
en realidad pueden llegar a ser bastante
hipnóticas finalmente vamos a crear
sistemas de partículas muchos objetos
que se mueven juntos de acuerdo a sus
propiedades y a las propiedades de los
sistemas que nos permitirá modelar
fenómenos naturales como el agua el
fuego el humo muy bien no suena
impresionante te sientes motivado estás
lanzando confeti al aire pensando que
tan pronto podrás programar ese confeti
conozco esa emoción y ya estás casi
listo para sumergirte en esto pero
primero queremos dar un agradecimiento
enorme a daniel shechtman danielle es un
profesor de la universidad de nueva york
que imparte un curso sobre simulaciones
naturales y escribió un libro entero
acerca de eso night tour of code
puntocom
lo que licenció su libro con cc podemos
portar la llave script y traerlo a khan
academy para que todos ustedes lo
aprendan incluyendo nuevos desafíos de
programación sin el libro de daniel no
tendríamos este curso tan emocionante
ahora en sus marcas listos a simular